[Music]
and look at this I mean that is not
clean that was just washed one week ago
stop just for once today blowing let's
see 30 seconds
did you have any idea you're sleeping in
that no I wish you can't see that print
I see that I want an explanation because
all you've done since I've arrived here
if you lied to me lie to me lie to your
staff and I am NOT gonna allow you to
lie to the customers and I totally
[ __ ] disagree with that too I have
not said one lie to you if I'm not gonna
go for that yes you have no I die it's
not true you convinced that thought food
is fresh food you're robbing them of
their cash you're telling me this was
cleaned a week ago let me ask you a
question in front of your customers
would you sleep on that no so why'd you
expect them to would you sleep on that
no not an apology
nothing I'd like to apologize and I'm
appalled I'm disgusted
I've had enough anything you like to say
the pillows like this I apologize for
have a word with him on my own
would you mind
these guests are hours away from putting
their heads on your pillows
blood-stained pillows semen-stained
duvet covers and sweat accumulated over
years I can see that going I am
struggling I'm struggling with your
husband that's in denial I'm struggling
with these arrogance and I'm struggling
with these blatant lies I'm not here to
buy head with a liar I'm here to help
turn this business around acne you can
talk to me are you worried about Brent
he's my husband
yes I am it's my life we have a daughter
together does your daughter feel this at
home yeah and he fell out with his son
he fired his son does that still bother
him
is that what it is he's still he's son
of course he's still his son care about
it doesn't sound like he's caring about
him
the guy was drinking he needed help they
got rid of him
is that what's bothering him is that why
he's in denial
I need Brent to take his guard down
something inside here is bothering him I
don't know if it's the financial debt
the pressure is a son I don't know I
can't get in I want to talk to his son
how can I get hold of him I got his
number
thank you after me you're the only hope
of God can we work together and can we
get him to open up at tomorrow morning I
want the truth and nothing but the truth
[Music]